one more clip of RFK on Rogan they
started talking about why Pharma and the
government and the media are all tied up
together in this endless
of insanity that is being sprung upon
all of us
they are able to dictate content on
television so they can dictate content
on the you know on the local and on
YouTube yeah of course yeah
that
that's a terrifying thing and it's so
deeply interwoven
the the question that I would have to
you is like how do you untangle that you
would do one of those things at a time
and I you know I'm going to go in there
and do it
I'm going to issue an executive order on
day one saying there's no more
advertising on TV now
FDA needs to implement that through the
regulatory process but I also know how
the regulatory process works and I know
how to hasten it I know how to make it
work faster for the American people so
you know I um I know I you know I'm
looking forward to doing this I'm
looking forward to
Helen after you hey you're not taking
Pharma money anymore
we are not governed by the FDA that is
what I think RFK Jr understands and they
put money into all of these programs
which then push their propaganda and
then they also and this is the key part
they also have connections and the
government has connections as we now
know because of the Twitter files with
all of the big tech companies right so
not only do they push out and sponsor
propaganda on mainstream media but then
for the people on YouTube
etc etc or just you at home just being
like you know I did see this study it's
a little outside of what mainstream me
I'm going to put that on Twitter bang
it's gone